this is a global news special
presentation
hello from harkeef this is freedom
square in ukraine's second largest city
a collection of government buildings and
businesses that have been blown out
boarded up we are just 40 kilometers
from the russian border and this region
was one of the first to be attacked in
the early hours of the invasion but
harkiv now stands as a testament to
ukrainian defiance and resilience which
have taken russia and the world by
surprise
i'm jeff sumple welcome to a global news
special 100 days in ukraine
russia's full-scale aggression against
the sovereign and democratic neighbor
that was a watershed moment
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
this was a russian tank
the work happening here is actually
critical
this is a war that's still being fought
and they're adding photographs of fallen
soldiers something to inspire people
they know we're here they know that
they're not alone
[Music]
thank you for joining us in some ways
it's hard to believe it's only been 100
days so much has happened so many lives
lost or forever changed since those
early hours of february the 24th when
russia launched the largest conventional
military attack since the second world
war
and in response over the past three
months global news correspondents have
crisscrossed this country reporting from
more than a dozen towns and cities from
la vie to harkeef odessa to dinipro and
the capital kiev we've also visited
neighboring nations moldova poland and
latvia amid fears they could be next on
russia's war path
but if vladimir putin hoped his invasion
would expand russia's sphere of
influence and reclaim remnants of the
soviet empire that high-stakes gambit
appears to have backfired eric sorenson
reports on the global consequences of
the conflict
what vladimir putin called a special
military operation was in fact his
declaration of war on ukraine
russian forces struck from the air and
on the ground and from all directions
ukrainian cities were bombarded
civilians killed and tens of thousands
panic-stricken ukrainians began flooding
across all its borders the russians are
not
a new divided gta i mean the russian
soldiers they kill children she says
they bomb schools
at first it looked like russia would
swallow ukraine and decapitate its
government putin and others thought the
capital kiev would fall within days it
was a gross miscalculation
the ukrainians fought back supported by
arms and intelligence from nato even
sinking a major russian warship he
thought he could roll into ukraine and
the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined
putin also underestimated president
vladimir zelinsky who many thought would
flee
a leader
we are here said zielinski with other
government leaders becoming a symbol and
inspiration to ukrainians and zielinski
motivated nations around the world to
help global leaders came together and
much of the world united to stand up to
russia
analyst marcus colga says vladimir putin
misjudged ukraine the west and even
russia's military capabilities i think
he overestimated himself
his generals that surround him and the
ability of his forces for russia what
began in february as a lightning
military campaign on multiple fronts in
march was stalled by ukrainian
resistance and counter-attacks by april
most russian troops had pulled back from
their assault on kiev and the north
russia shifting its focus to the east a
smaller campaign for the donbass and a
land bridge through mariopol to connect
to russian-held crimea this is the
territory russia seems determined to
hold
putin has told russians all is going
according to plan but one more strategic
failure is plain to see
the brutal invasion of its neighbor has
caused other neighbors sweden and
finland to prepare to join nato russia's
goal of keeping the western alliance
away from its border is backfiring
spectacularly russia's full-scale
aggression against the sovereign and
democratic neighbor
that was a watershed moment the last 100
days have demonstrated that when the
west stands together we have a chance to
fight back against these sorts of
authoritarians but for all that has gone
wrong for russia there are no signs that
putin is losing his grip on power that
he can and will fight on we assess
president putin is preparing for
prolonged conflict in ukraine
in the first 100 days ukraine has
withstood an onslaught and if the next
100 become a grinding war for territory
one question looms what would each side
accept to bring about peace
many of ukraine's military victories
have been fought and won with western
weapons nato allies have supplied an
arsenal ranging from rocket launchers to
anti-tank weapons to machine guns and
one group of foreign volunteers is
providing much more than fire power
at a secret location in western ukraine
these ukrainian civilians are receiving
a specialized training course
they're learning to fight
like wolverines
this is something new and special i've
never been part of anything like this
before
last month after russian forces suffered
a crushing defeat near ukraine's capital
residents surveying the damage came
across a peculiar site abandoned russian
military vehicles spray painted with the
word wolverines the photos shared on
social media sparked international
intrigue over who was responsible
[Music]
well now the secretive group is stepping
out of the shadows for the first time
granting global news exclusive access
inside their operation
we're going in loud and we're going in
fast
the wolverines are led by around 100
volunteers from 20 countries american
british and canadian combat veterans and
former special forces
here to fight the russians and train the
ukrainians because a lot of these guys
don't have any training this wolverine's
instructor is from bc the more people we
can train that's more people who can
help defend the country so we can do a
lot more by
training the guys here than just going
to the front
over three months they provided this
week-long crash course to more than six
thousand ukrainians from soldiers to
civilians i learned a lot literally a
lot from the guys this ukrainian one of
the first to be trained had no combat
experience
now he's training others
how it was three months ago how i am now
is completely different level the
wolverines and their ukrainian students
then head together to the front lines
armed with guns and cans of spray paint
to leave their mark
it's
something to inspire people people see
it
they know we're here they know that
they're not alone and it seems that
message is getting through
[Applause]
a ukrainian pop star just released this
music video dedicated to the wolverines
meanwhile in central ukraine they took
down this soviet statue and replaced it
with a wolverines tagged tank
this was like a beacon of hope for our
guys it really was that the people are
getting it they see it they're out there
they love it but also this has an impact
on the psychology of the russians you
know to know that the world has united
against them
we're here
and he says they're here to stay until
the war
is won
ukraine says it's investigating more
than 10 thousand possible russian war
crimes and has identified at least 600
suspects many of those alleged
atrocities were committed in bucha near
the ukrainian capital crystal commansing
visited the city and found families on a
heartbreaking hunt for their loved ones
it is a small white tent but the
structure gives shelter to those seeking
answers every day dozens of survivors
come here searching for their dead loved
ones
this woman found her 15 year old
grandson's body her cries set against
the steady hum of the refrigerator truck
holding his remains and so many others
agonizing searches have been ongoing
since the moment russian forces were
driven out of bucha the city's 50
thousand residents were bombed and
terrorized for days
bucha was considered the most dangerous
place near keith
my work day is like this they are
calling calling calling and it's like
hundreds of people i have to talk every
day work at the morgue is never ending
tanks have been removed streets cleared
but for the residents of bucha who
survived they are now in another phase
of this war
grief we opened here
information center as the butcher city
council and we are helping relatives to
find their
killed or died
moms fathers daughters sons well the
images of bodies piled up is graphic and
unsettling the work happening here is
actually critical the bodies will hold
evidence potentially answering key
questions about what happened here that
can be used by international
investigators to build a war crimes case
against russia
two teams spend every morning here
performing post-mortems and then
meticulously documenting their findings
in the afternoon
i wake up every morning at 3 o'clock and
victor and yuri already in front of my
eyes nadia valentina and sirhi found
their two relatives after a month-long
search they tell us it appears nadia's
ex-husband and his brother were tortured
their loss is devastating especially for
certi i didn't talk to local creatures
sergey cried and shouted so loudly
begging them to live a life at least one
of them for him
it is impossible to escape the horrors
of this war and some of those bearing
witness to it are so young
they'll carry the memories for a
lifetime
coming up babies in a bomb shelter how
one hospital is caring for sick infants
in a war
[Music]
zone we're here in the city of odessa in
southern ukraine and this city is widely
thought to be one of vladimir putin's
next targets right on the black sea as a
result people here have been preparing
in a number of ways and this is one of
them you see this staircase that has
just been opened up here leads down to a
series of tunnels
the catacombs below the city actually go
down about four stories very deep and
they were dug back in the 19th century
at the time people
were using the materials from below the
ground to help build houses above
during the second world war
these tunnels were turned into shelters
and they are being repurposed once again
with the looming threat of invasion from
russia and as you can see local
residents here have been busy at work
they have set up electricity here
there's even wi-fi
wireless internet setup in these tunnels
other people have brought down food
supplies
water bedding allowing them if needed to
stay down here for a couple of days and
these 200 year old tunnels are now
providing a lifeline for a city under
threat
some of those tunnels and bunkers are
even being transformed into makeshift
hospital rooms including one facility we
visited that was caring for some of
odessa's smallest residents
i just want to cry i just want to shout
to other countries to please help us
said tatiana picatilieva
she runs this children's hospital in
odessa about a hundred kilometers from
the front line some of their patients
just arrived from the war zone including
a newborn
pakitillava says they've been spending a
lot of time down here
beneath the hospital a series of bunkers
previously used for storage now
converted into fortified hospital rooms
when they hear the air raid sirens up to
four times each day staff bring the
patients down here in case the hospital
is hit
we play films for the children so they
can't hear the bombs she says but this
is not a fortress we wouldn't withstand
a direct hit christina mitry zimlet's 12
year old son mark suffers from a rare
lung disorder the spiderman superfan
relies on a machine to help him breathe
asked if he's afraid of the war
he says no i laugh at fear many of their
friends and family have already left the
country
we're desperate to leave but my son
requires special treatment equipment and
transportation she says we're trapped
here until we can find a safe way out
even the journey down into the bunker
can be difficult for him for others it's
impossible
this unit cares for sick newborns many
born prematurely this baby just had
stomach surgery
these babies cannot be moved into the
bomb shelter because they rely on this
life-saving equipment their doctor says
they would not survive she and her nine
colleagues were given the choice when
the air sirens sound go down into the
shelter or stay here exposed
all of them chose to stay
how can someone destroy a hospital like
the one in mariupol she says there are
no words
thousands of civilians have been killed
during 100 days of war along with an
unknown number of ukrainian soldiers
many have had their funerals held at a
church in western ukraine which has a
special relationship with the ukrainian
military mike armstrong reports from
levief
it has been a very busy week at this
church there was a funeral held
wednesday at levi's garrison church of
the holy apostles peter and paul it was
a service for three fallen soldiers a
day before there was a funeral for two
and a day before that three more
admits being a military chaplain at a
time of war is hard psychologically
burying so many young men or as he calls
them boys
their lives that should have had many
years left this week they've had
soldiers who've just started families
some who were just married and one who
didn't quite make it that far
father kazek says one of the soldiers
had just proposed to his girlfriend and
then went to fight
now this church has a relationship with
the military that goes back three
centuries off to the side of this church
there are posters that the faces of
soldiers lost in a war that people here
will tell you didn't start two weeks ago
it began with the occupation of crimea
they've been adding posters here since
2014.
now they also have these boards this is
a war that's still being fought and
they're adding photographs of fallen
soldiers individually as they're killed
was a 28 year old senior lieutenant his
fiancee and his close family attended
the military funeral in la vie but there
was another
ushevani grew up in a village about an
hour outside the city that entire
village came out to pay their respects
this man says vushavani was a patriot
his loss the sacrifice of a brave young
man
[Music]
now in just two weeks the two sides in
this conflict have lost thousands of
soldiers those are statistics if you
don't have a name
everyone here on this day knew
at least one
coming up
tries to get back on track we returned
to ukraine's second city to find
devastation and stolen russian tanks
[Music]
welcome back there's perhaps no city in
ukraine that better exemplifies the
trajectory of this war more than harkev
the first time we visited this city was
back in march and it appeared to be on
the brink of falling to the russians but
today is a much different reality
during the first weeks of war families
sheltered underground huddled together
in subway stations to avoid the bombing
above
but two months later their lives are
slowly getting back on track
subway service in harkev resumed for the
first time since russia's invasion
and commuters were on board
it's excellent it feels like things are
returning to the way they were before
this passenger says
the mayor of harkev whom we met two
months ago in a secret bomb shelter
appeared this time in public
and told reporters we need to restart
the economy people must be able to get
to work
this russian-speaking city sits on
russia's doorstep but ukraine has pushed
russian forces back almost to the border
and it seems some left in a hurry this
was a russian tank that is until it was
captured by the ukrainian forces in a
battle with the russians in harkev last
month and the ukrainians brought it here
to this secret location so that
ukrainian soldiers can train and learn
how to use it so this is a look inside
they say it's similar in many ways but
it's a newer model and it's much faster
so they have to learn how to handle it
they say that this thing can go up to
100 kilometers an hour in fact they've
nicknamed it the flying tank
in three months the ukrainians have
captured more than 240 russian tanks
they say they even use this one to
attack a russian battalion and kill its
commander
our enemy has gone from attacking to
defending this ukrainian sergeant says
our spies say the russians are
demoralized but while the city hopes the
worst is over the scars of war are
brutal
this family survived the bombing of
their apartment building and came to
inspect their son's kindergarten across
the street
they found his school playground full of
fragments from russian rockets
russia says it's attacking military
targets but this is a quiet neighborhood
with schools and houses she says the
family called the ordinance disposal
unit to remove this grad rocket from
beneath the play structure
this team has their hands full
the rockets are everywhere he says
in the span of just a couple of hours
his unit was called to remove ordinance
from this apartment kitchen a nearby
parking lot and yet another kindergarten
playground
signs that harkive still has a long way
to go on its road to
recovery most music clubs and concert
halls remain closed in harkev but
recently a group of musicians and poets
held a small concert here connected via
video link with levive on the other side
of the country to raise funds for
ukraine's military we leave you now with
one of their songs
i'm jeff semple thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign